This quantum computer is too powerful.
Let's see how it works.
Hello world it Saroj in.
Anyone who has a laptop and an Internet
connection can now use a quantum
computer to submit and run applications
receiving solutions in seconds.
The waves leap service is the first
cloudbase quantum application environment
that gives developers real time
access to alive quantum computer.
In this video,
we'll use the leap service to build a
simple application to monitor a crop
health sensor network.
Quantum computing is already being
applied to early real world applications.
Volkswagen,
for example,
first used data from 418 taxis and
Beijing to see how well a quantum computer
could optimize the travel
time of taxis in the city.
Based on that success,
VW has stated that they are working
on putting their algorithm to use
commercially for traffic management.
In Lisbon.
Recruit communications applied it to
optimize the efficiency of matching
advertisements to customers for web
advertising and recently announced they
could increase sales using a quantum
algorithm from cryptography to medicine to
financial markets.
Quantum computing can be applied to
almost every industry to solve real
problems.
Quantum mechanics is the
body of scientific laws
that describe the motion and
interaction of photons,
electrons,
and other subatomic particles
that make up our universe.
Quantum computers exploit the rules of
quantum mechanics to solve problems,
and these rules are hard for
us to conceptualize because
there are so different
than what we're used to.
Let's say we flipped the coin,
we know what will happen.
It'll go up and then down
and land on heads or tails.
These are all single truths, but if
we shrunk down to the subatomic level,
and again flip the coin,
there would be multiple truths.
The coin would be in both heads and
tails simultaneously in the air.
It could be 60% heads and 40%
tails, for example, simultaneously,
and he would stay in midair until it's
observed by some measuring device,
be it a human or a machine. Pretty
Wild, right? To quote Dr Feinman,
if you think you understand
quantum mechanics,
you don't understand quantum mechanics.
Quantum computing exploits
three key features of quantum
mechanics for computing.
Superposition,
entanglement and quantum tunneling
particles can exist across all possible
states simultaneously.
And this is known as a superposition
of states and electron, for example,
may exist in two possible spin states
usually referred to as spin up and spin
down simultaneously.
And sometimes groups of particles interact
in ways such that the quantum state
of each particle cannot be described
independently of the state of the others,
even when the particles are
separated by a large distance.
This is called entanglement and quantum
tunneling helps quantum computers
explore the space of all
possible solutions to a
problem which can be thought of
as low line points in a mountainous
terrain by drilling through all the
mountains simultaneously rather
than having to go over them.
D-Wave invited me to Vancouver to see
their quantum computer in person and it
was an incredible experience.
I saw that while a classical computer
uses bits that perform computation there,
quantum machine uses cubits.
So in San up taking on the
value of either zero or one,
it can take on both at the same
time in a super imposed state.
And these cubits can be entangled with
each other to compute huge amounts of
data and solve certain complex problems
that would take classical computers
millions of years to calculate.
The way this is done is not by using what
we're used to that classical see moss
or complimentary metal oxide
semiconductor transistor,
but instead what's called
a squid or superconducting
quantum interference device,
Aka quantum transistors.
Instead of using silicon,
it uses a metal called neodymium that
when cooled below negative 264 degrees
Celsius becomes a super conductor and
starts to exhibit quantum mechanical
effects.
While irregular transistor only lets
us encode to different states using
voltages,
accubid can encode to states as tiny
magnetic fields that can point up or down
simultaneously couplers connect cubits
together as such that they can exchange
information easily. As amazing as
quantum machines are, let's be clear,
they are not a replacement for
classical computers. Instead,
they're complimentary for a
subset of classical problems.
Quantum computing will
make a dramatic difference.
We can in fact think of the quantum
computation process as engineering the
pattern of a complex set of waves in
hope of channeling the flow towards the
correct answer.
So let's take a look at the leap service
firsthand to see what it offers us.
We can sign up for an
account on the landing page.
Then we'll be able to access the dashboard
here we can see how much time we have
to use the quantum
processing unit or QP you.
It doesn't seem like a lot of time,
but it is because quantum
computers are so fast,
they can perform computations
in just milliseconds.
There are a whole host of learning
materials on this dashboard including
educational videos,
research publications,
and real world case studies that show
how their clients have used their quantum
computer to solve customer problems.
The Community Support Tab also leads to
access to their technical forums that
allow developers to share and
learn about quantum computing.
My favorite part of the dashboard or the
interactive demos that can be viewed in
the browser to learn more about specific
use cases as well as Jupiter notebooks
that demonstrate different
quantum algorithms. In the cloud.
The ocean Sdk is the waves python library
that wraps the API and lets us access
to QP you in a simple three step process.
After installing it using
the popular pip installer,
we just set our API token and we can
verify our connection to the CUPE you with
the D Wave Ping Command.
So for our use case,
imagine we're a software as a service
startup that creates custom sensor
networks for farmers so that they
get crop information in real time,
allowing them to make smarter decisions.
We can build a network of devices that
can sense water quality, air pollution,
crop health,
and more.
Then we'll want to create a
security system that ensures
that this system is not
compromised by a third party and the
data's stolen will want to monitor network
traffic as it moves
between all of our routers.
We could place a traffic monitor on
every single device in our network,
but that would be an expensive
hardware cost. Instead,
what if we placed network traffic
sensors in the minimum amount of spots
necessary such that the sensors are
still able to monitor all traffic in the
network?
We can consider this a graph problem.
Nodes are sensor outposts
full of different equipment
and the edges represent
all the paths that data flows through.
Between these notes,
we're trying to find what's called the
minimum vertex cover of vertex cover is a
set of vertices such that each edge of
the graph is incident with at least one
vertex in the set.
A minimum for techs cover then is
the vertex cover of smallest size.
Let's open our own cloud notebook
using the leap service to solve an
optimization problem.
We can visualize a simple example of
this using the network x Python package.
It's used to study the structure of
complex networks. After importing it,
we can create a five node
star graph in a single line.
The minimum set of vertices that
touch all edges is node zero.
That's the solution to
this simple problem,
but the general problem of finding
as such a set is NP hard. Well first,
solve this problem on a CPU.
Since first a small number of variables,
it's possible to compute classically
in a relatively short time.
Then we'll do it on
the QP you to solve it.
On the CPU will initialize a sampler
using the exact solver module of the
official Die Mod Api.
A solver is a resource that runs a
problem and samplers are processes that
sample from low energy states of
a problems. Objective function,
which is a mathematical expression
of the energy of a system.
The sampler we've initialized returns a
binary models value for every possible
assignment of variable values.
This is a collection of binary valued
variable that are variables that can be
assigned to values like negative one
and one with associated linear and
quadratic biases. Uh, Bq m samplers,
samples from low energy states in one of
the default models defined by d wave in
the API and returns an iterable of
samples in order of increasing energy.
This helps formulate
optimization problems.
Then we can use the wave network's library
to produce a Bq m four our grab and
solve it on our select sampler.
We're not explicitly creating the Bq em,
it's obstructed by the ocean tool.
So given the problem graph,
it returns a solution to a Bq
em that it creates internally.
Now to solve it on a quantum processor,
we can use a d wave sampler and a new
addition. The embedding composite.
This maps unstructured problems to the
graph structure of the selected sampler
via a process called minor embedding.
Our problem star graph must be mapped
to the qps numerically indexed cubits.
We'll see that it creates a new
graph and solves it on the QP you.
We can know that this solution
isn't unique. In fact,
there are multiple valid solutions.
When we give our algorithm a much larger
graph that consists of real world data,
it will perform the same tasks and we
can use the output as a guide as to where
exactly we should place
traffic monitoring equipment.
We now know the least amount of equipment
we need to buy to monitor the entire
network. A lot to take in all at once.
I know, but it's a very exciting field.
There are three things to
remember from this video.
The waves leap is the first cloud based
quantum application environment that
gives developers realtime access
to allied quantum computer.
Quantum computing uses three key features
from quantum mechanics to perform
computations,
including superposition.
Entanglement and tunneling,
and we can solve the minimum bird techs
problem for a graph much faster using a
quantum machine than a classical one.
Also,
coding challenge for the week.
Create a simple application
using leap that solves a problem.
I'll give a shout out next week to the
top two entries and a special prize for
number one. I'm looking for great
documentation and an interesting use case.
Good luck wizards.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos and for now I'll get a stop
interfering.
So thanks for watching.